what do you remember about that day that
you said this will be my last time
picking up a camera I don't remember the
day you know so I I don't remember the
day that was okay this is gonna be the
last time but can I flip it and tell you
about the day that I got that that light
back I was and I this was not in the
email or anything I was are you guys
familiar Bob Proctor by chance yes he's
like a motivational yeah and he was very
active in the DVD
Rhonda Burns wrote a book but for the
secret yes so the whole manifestation
thing right and it's like I think if I
can give any kind of recipe to anybody
it's it's about that but I was in my
studio and was by myself and I was
frustrated that people weren't
volunteering to help me you know unpack
like boxes upon boxes of stuff right and
something told me that I need to so just
when I say put my camera down for about
eight months about five of that or six
months of that was before I got into the
studio and then I started slowly picking
back up as I had the studio but it took
a while and I had the studio for three
years about you know but I in the
beginning one of the these glimmers of
light that I had was I was looking for I
thought I really want to watch the
secret DVD again okay I have to find the
DVD player cuz you know it's not such a
commonly used thing and I knew it was in
a box somewhere and I had to find the TV
somewhere it was just like a disaster of
a place and I was looking for this DVD
for three days I did not find it and I
looked everywhere through every box and
after about three days I thought you
know what I just need to get this place
in renting condition so people can start
renting and I can start making money
from it and I got a call from a friend
that said hey can I refer you to
somebody and it's a friend of a
and I thought sure so I got a call and
it's and and on my cell and I said hello
and the person said is why lead there
and normally if you pronounce my name
well lead then I know that you somehow
know me but if it's wallet because it's
wal ID then I know that it's some there
selling yourself something exactly right
my attitude changes between the wallet
and the wall either Mike oh hey you know
because I might know them and she said
hi my name is Lisa I'm calling you
because I got your number from Dustin
and he are I my name is Lisa I'm calling
you because yeah Our Mutual Friend
Dustin shared your number with me and I
worked for Bob Proctor and he wants to
photograph with you and he's putting out
a book and he's putting out more
seminars and we're expanding his reach
and and she's like are you familiar with
Bob Proctor and I I was like yeah like
it but I didn't say I didn't fan out
entirely I didn't say that right he says
the intro and everything and that was so
when Bob Proctor wanted to shoot with me
that was this weird I felt like this
divine moment of something is telling me
something but I had no idea what and so
my producer Matt I said Matt here's your
budget you know normal thing here's a
budget for craft services and food and
everything and I said I don't care take
out of my check make sure that there's
nice flowers and make sure that it's
above and beyond and I told you earlier
that I didn't think I was an artist
anymore and that's the part that hurt
the most I just doubted my skills and
bob was in hair makeup and I was across
the studio setting up the next lighting
setup and it was a very light walk and
he walked up behind me and put his hand
on my shoulder and he said you know well
he'd I feel like I need to tell you this
he said I've shot with a lot of
photographers in my whole career and
he's like you're different than all of
them
and he said I just think I you need to
know that you're an artist and that was
so that was this weird moment I think I
remember even my eyes kind of teared up
at that moment and then he went back and
did Bob things and you know put on his
jacket and everything that to me so when
you say do I remember when I put my
camera down I actually don't remember
when I put my camera down for the last
time but I do remember when I picked it
up and thought maybe there's something
still in me and I started working
towards that so you had been looking for
this DVD and it was in boxes and the TV
was about and and yeah in what time
frame again sorry did you get this call
after you were at the third day when I
said I'm done looking did the phone ring
that's crazy
yeah and so when my friend said my
friend Dustin said can I share a number
somebody I thought whatever I'm probably
gonna say no anyways but whatever and it
end up being
Lisa who works at Bob Proctor you know
and it's amazing yeah so we shot twice
now he comes you know I really like
couple years for new pictures and so Bob
Proctor had a lot to do with me picking
back up wow that's really powerful did
you ever tell him the story no because I
thought that would be embarrassing yeah
no don't tell ya look it's like when my
mom bought me when I worked for Usher
and she bought me uh sure x' cologne and
I was like oh you know like you know he
should be freaked out and I was like can
you please take this back well and and
this is I don't know if this is
something worth exploring but for people
that aren't used to the LA celebrity
culture don't stare at them don't don't
fana you know I'm saying like yes you
want to be human with them but at the
same time they get so many vultures yep
and people with like crazy agendas that
even if your intentions are pure they're
gonna be freaked out yep and their staff
is gonna be freaked out yep
and so that is a weird thing too
kind of like settle into yeah once I
mean I'm sure I don't you probably have
stories or you just have to just it's
almost like it's just another day at the
job yeah if you do that it's gonna put
them off yeah I think that when you do
meet somebody that's legendary or r4u
legendary whoever somebody a viewer
might love um
learn how to have a heart attack inside
and keep your face calm you know just go
I've had those you know and most random
of all people most random and I've met
some huge people I'm like hi how are you
mwah lead but some that I'm like like I
found out because I saw Laura Diaz from
KBC Channel 7 News I'm like oh my god
like I grew up watching her you know and
um so dumb but I did you know yeah cuz
you feel like you know her yeah it was a
weirdest thing is the weirdest thing
Tony Bennett freaked out and inside but
I started actually sweating Bernie
Sanders Wow that one inside I was like
oh my god oh my god you know but some
people it just is you just don't know so
just learn how to how to have a heart
attack inside keep calm but also I think
just talk to them about normal things
and I notice that people say things like
um oh I think I thought you were
brilliant and no they're not brilliant
if they found the cure for cancer
they're brilliant
they acted really really well or they
wrote a beautiful screenplay but this
whole worshipping I think it freaks them
out a lot yeah and I think it was genius
really yeah it's too much gushing I mean
I've heard stories of people being
followed into bathrooms and their
expresstoll and someone's outside
pitching them or something and yeah that
I mean but even just the whole like
staring at someone for too long more
oranges and trying to like be in their
little space yeah it's like they've
dealt with that so much they just don't
do that yeah just human right
[Music]
you